hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the long-awaited return
of don't starve this time featuring yes
someone made a mod for this game
featuring me and created myself along
with tiny box Tim in this game and
that's amazing and I feel so bad because
it's taking me so long to find it thank
you so much fit do fi do ooo P and
friends who have contributed to this
thank you so much for making this I
can't believe it took me this long to
get to it but I'm gonna play it right
now and hopefully that makes it up to
you sincerely I love playing things that
the community even creates for me people
have made actual games about me there's
been markiplier the game 1 & 2 you can
find more games that people have made
for me in the description down below and
I'm so grateful because I can't believe
that someone would actually take the
time to make something about me I mean
it's it's a weird thing but I guess it
comes natural considering I play a lot
of games so sincerely thank you so much
for making this mod and let's find out
what is involved oh that's awesome I've
been watching your videos for quite some
time now but I don't think you're too
pro as you call yourself really well you
didn't fare so well last time you were
here well you didn't watch very closely
so I challenge you Oh have you now I
even brought one of your good friends to
help me out you out me oh okay I need to
calm down because that is the most
adorable thing I've ever seen in my life
I knew tiny bugs Tim was in here but I
didn't know that he'd be that adorable
how's he gonna follow me yes I'm so
happy right now thank you sincerely
thank you so much for making this for me
um gosh it has been forever since I
played don't starve sorry I got really
excited there but SAP scares me is that
something that I say I don't know if
that's me or if that's just something
that you wrote into the game bring it
away honestly
I'm honored that anyone thinks that it's
worth their time to make something about
me so the fact that someone did he's
just incredible now I'm playing the
reign of giants mod I was actually
worried that this might not function
correctly with it but it seems to be
doing just fine so far and I cannot wait
to see what other features are in the
game now it has been a long time since I
played don't starve like a good seven
eight nine months maybe since the last
time I actually picked it up but most of
the functionality of the game I seem to
remember in my head and need to craft
items it's a very survivalist game
there's a day/night cycle if you don't
recall any of it I do have a long
playthrough of it it's not really a
terribly exciting action-oriented game
but it is very interesting to see this
world in the stylization that it's that
it's taken and the developers made for
it it's really an intricate intricate
game apologize I can't talk today I've
been recording a lot of videos in
advance just because I've been trying to
pack up because once again bob is
getting married I'm going to Cincinnati
for one day a red-eye on the way over
and a red-eye on the way back so that it
can make this bachelor party and then
two weeks later I will be going down to
Cincinnati again for about five days in
order to make the wedding itself and see
some family and some friends that I had
missed since I have been in Los Angeles
but either way I'm just biding time
because I'm picking up oh I didn't even
notice that I didn't know if I was
twirling my mustache there I was picking
my ear so I'm gonna assume that I was
twirling my mustache oh that is so cool
thank you so much everyone who
contributed this I want some peanuts now
jeez alright okay I don't know what's
going on why can't I eat these I don't
think I should eat this well maybe that
one but it's like a game or something
never know what you'll get I don't know
what you're talking about sir I don't
even know who you are anymore but anyway
I'm gonna try to guide how do I did I
okay for some reason I can't get the
berries past my mustache well that is
something that is a personal
for me but I need to get this anyway
because they need to get some wood oh
yeah I got a click and hold Oh musics
are coming is there a giant gonna be
coming plowing down the way what's up
Bertinelli a birch nut is that edible is
that close to a peanut will that's a she
ate you mister markiplier sir and your
two proneness I don't know why but it
makes me so happy to see him like tiny
bison was just one of those weird things
where I saw something cute and I have
this weird thing where ever whenever I
see something tiny like I'd go into a
shoe store and I'll see tiny baby shoes
I lose my mind they're so adorable that
I cannot help but running up to him and
grabbing them and like showing them to
everyone I know that how cute they are
they are the most adorable things and
tiny Buxton was just one of those things
girls like oh man and you guys are gonna
see more of tiny bugs Tim very soon if
you know what I mean but you don't
because I'm going to no you don't know
but there's something come along very
soon so you'll be very excited about
that I'm sure anyway i bided enough time
I need to start the process of surviving
because it's about to be night I was
hoping it's almost time to take my pants
off well unlucky for you something you
got wrong mr. Ford OOP my pants are
never on I'm not wearing any right now
and I'd prove it but it'd be
inappropriate for the YouTube audience
but anyway this is so cool I can't even
believe it it's been a long time since I
played this game and this game is very
fun I would recommend it to anyone the
reign of giants expansion I think is
only five dollars now I don't know how
much content adadz or what it changes in
terms of the general gameplay fires
getting low that's not good keyboard guy
okay are you talking to me I don't know
who you're talking to this is a meta
conversation I'm having with myself
I mean I do spend most of my day inside
playing video games in front of a
computer I do not recall myself being
this pale maybe that's just a style of
everyone in this world in this strange
sunless land there is no escape from the
darkness but either way the objective of
this game is very simple it's don't die
I mean I've never managed to get to the
end of it I've played it on a live
stream wants to try to get as far as I
could and I had this adventure mode
survival thing where I actually found
the portal maxwell's portal that started
you on the trip to actually getting to
the end of the game and then I did play
this creature mod which was a horror mod
for don't starvin God that was actually
quite terrifying and I would recommend
anyone who likes horror games to watch
that I'll put a link of that in the
description as well I've just been
trying to find more food and foraging
around because the most of the beginning
of this game is just foraging you're
gonna be foraging for a while but I'm
trying to find out what other markiplier
specific stuff they have found or they
have added to the game don't even know I
sure like to whack that mole thing well
there's no such luck in this department
because he's made it he's - he's too sly
he's to escape worthy oh oh okay so now
is the time when this campfire is
actually important so I'm lucky that I
have this now time to take my pants off
oh no more pants off dance off I don't
know what that was doesn't have anything
to do with me give me your tiny bucks
Tim my little biscuit don't stand too
close to the fire Tim you're gonna get
burned up don't even worry about that
need to put some fuel on that fire don't
burn up tiny box no tiny box Tim come on
stay away from the fire I know you're
trying to get warm but I'm worried about
you safety I don't know what I'd do if
anything happened to you I don't know
you so much okay anyway so now I need it
okay oh Jesus is that [ __ ]
mr. mole man huh something's under there
searching for minerals huh all right no
I can cook this meat hook it up get some
nice cooked morsels lads doesn't look
like it that looks like an uptown
mushroom okey dokey either way that's
gonna help me a little bit I've been
not watching my is can you cook these I
have no idea I don't think so I haven't
been watching my hunger which is
basically the entire principle of the
game is not starving so anyway there's
more stuff that you can do but I'm
really only trying to find out what
specific stuff to me that was added to
the game if there is nothing more than
that's totally fine I don't mind that
right by berry bushes in Sandy so the
day night cycle if you don't know about
the game if you do obviously you already
have played this game before but the
day/night cycle it works very bad to go
out at night and very good to go out in
the day and in the evening it's just a
warning to go to bed take off your pants
snuggle up to someone close you love or
no or just met that night and have a
good old time in that advice from market
bar don't listen to me I don't know what
I'm talking about
MDM knows the different Tim Tim that's a
Toby Turner Tim Tim Feeny little rabbit
that does sound like something I would
say alright fine you can live for one
day tiny box Tim wouldn't want me to
kill all the wooden creatures just yet
dynamite Zuma you and I are gonna have a
fun adventure oh and I bone no but
that's that's another competitor that
tiny bystander
there's no way no no oh no yes sir
no oh now I got society by sim I hope
they don't fight it so cute I love
jester I thought tiny about sim replaced
jester but they're both in the same one
I'm so happy right now god I'm gonna use
my living house though at me I'm
ridiculously happy right now no no no I
I don't even know wormhole I'm not going
in there that day some low sanity to go
into a wormhole let's go in alone Dan
about zooming [ __ ] Saha oh let me get
that berry bush before we go don't know
what's gonna happen warning before I
jump into a giant gaping hole with teeth
in it but then again none of this makes
sense
Jimmy
hey is anybody gonna kill me on the
other side I feel violated god it's
weird cuz these are things that I might
actually say and it's surprisingly
accurate okay where did my abit is it
you know it's not gold it's whatever you
call it
buh buh buh buh come here
tiny box Tim I have a job for you you're
gonna carry the lugs data box iam gonna
box do em Thank You tiny box Tim you're
just the best you're gonna have that
you're gonna have the bird yes you can
you can hold on to my work - you're the
only one I would ever trust to wear that
tiny box Tim god I've never even seen a
tiny box similar to Worf's - I'm just
bursting to tell you what I have planned
for tiny box Tim in the future but I
can't tell you until it's definite solid
yes yes yes I know what's going on so
just let the anticipation build up and
know that there's gonna be something
that you guys are gonna love you guys
are gonna absolutely love it I can't say
anything more guests in the common oh no
do whatever you want the comments below
all right so I don't know how much more
there is and I'm not gonna start up the
series again unfortunately for don't
starving guys really really want me to
do more episodes but I played it out
pretty much to the maximum that it was I
may do it on a live stream I'm planning
to do some live streams very soon in the
future so if you guys want me to play it
again I will most likely be able to play
it on the live stream if that is what
you guys so desire but anyway just
carrying on around the world don't see
much else I don't know where the reign
of giants is I thought there was
supposed to be giants I haven't seen
anything yet I'm gonna have to
eventually build a camp I can't just
keep wandering around forever because oh
I'm back there I keep dancing up
everyone some Allah knows that I don't
know who did the animation for tiny box
Tim but that is a excellent animation of
the way joints with a little arm up not
doing like that but you know what I mean
stop your face selfie of a smoke alarm
an even more
sophmore give more inside your skull it
in face with you maybe not I don't know
maybe I'm abusive to myself here but hey
it's me I can do whatever I want right
Oh gold nugget well this is comforting
good thing this is all here goes good
idea whoops clicked outside the game
apologize everybody I can't oh god I
gotta get to build this science machine
that's right
so I need to take this I need to take
the ax I need to chop the logs I need to
equip that come in tiny box em I need
your logs thank you need to get that
there oh no wait well I have those I
need to put those there so I can make
the science machine it's getting dark
everywhere anyway why not camp it in the
middle of the graveyard all right
handsome bright head he is maybe I could
build me a shovel genius yes I am the
smartest there ever was because I'm
about to dig graves give me your [ __ ]
whoa red gem how nice
not a mark grave huh might have
something good stuff Gords not get out
of here
desiccated tentacle um Chester can take
that one I wouldn't put that on tine
about sim yes you love it shove those
desiccated tentacles inside your mouth
not dirty get your mind out of the
gutter hardened rubber ring okay
bathroom Chester Oh God could this get
any worse when why are there also gold
nuggets strewn about the graveyard here
seems mildly concerning but I'm not that
concerned oddly enough okay give me some
more of your goodies here hon rub a bath
ring hello no no no no no no no no Oh
so with that in there I'm actually also
gonna store you and you in
yeah you okay Fangio need to dig some
more so please Oh
life-giving amulet that's nice I like
that wait a minute my sanity is getting
lower and lower almost as if someone
doesn't like me taking up these graves
hey totally sane people have dug up
graves before there's no reason to go
insane I have a very strong capability
to not go insane that not many people
are believing that I'm saying right now
but it's true
thanks for the protection of the
elements am I talking to the trees now
can I feel the textures okay oh god
that's crazy oh no no no no no no no no
it's getting wild and crazy
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I can't even words right now I just
overdo the mic so much oh my god that is
the coolest thing I've ever seen in my
entire life that is so unbelievably cool
I think I'm running out on the cool down
on it oh I'm glad I get played
[Music]
okay okay little piggy no no a my son
like warthog creature a mile where
piggie
a mile where piggy I'm pretty sure I
might be aware piggy and I'm not
mistaken that is just the coolest I've
ever seen in my life whoever made this
mod you are the king of everything in my
book all my fans should go support
whatever the hell you make I don't even
know what you make other than this I'm
gonna find out I'm gonna put a link in
the description below to whatever you do
because this is one over the entire
internet for me you win all of the
Internet thank you so much holy moly
oh the darkness is creeping in okay so
anyway holy crap that was awesome
seriously thank you guys so much for
doing this for me that was crazy
oh my god I blew my mic so much but I
was totally worth it either way I'm
gonna cut it here because I don't think
that there's anything else
in terms of the markiplier mod that I
want I need to play if there is if there
is and I find out about it I will
definitely make a video about it in the
future you are awesome and let me
actually read off there was a bunch of
names for the people that helped out
with it so do Valka the letter W mr.
Nick and M tittles
Laurence caustics ro Chinese or Japanese
name that I can't read Clive forums link
oh this is for the forum leads but
either way thank you one and all who
involved in this Thank You tiny wags
ever being here and thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
one more videos that I've done
especially more games that people have
been made for me and if they you know
about games that were made for me that I
have not played yet please let me know
any way you can thank you again
everybody and as always I will see you
in the next video bye bye
[Music]